[Musik]
hier ist die korona krise geschafft
restaurants wieder voll cafés wieder auf
kneipen wieder voll besetzt teilweise
zumindest draußen und sie sie genießen
das das sind ihre persönlichen
glücksmomente gewesen an diesem langen
pfingstwochenende aber hier hier ist
noch tiefste corona krise an
deutschlands schulen fast nichts geht
dort nach wie vor die regierung hat
deutschlands schüler und schülerinnen zu
corona verlierern gemacht und wir
konfrontieren die regierung gleich mit
corona verlierern dazu haben wir uns
gleich zwei minister eingeladen nämlich
ihnen hier den bundeswirtschaftsminister
peter altmaier und sie die
bundesbildungsministerin anja karliczek
beide heute bei bild beide 30 minuten
lang beide stellen sich ihrem ärger
ihren fragen den richtigen fragen
[Musik]
minister nummer eins ist hier peter
altmaier der bundeswirtschaftsminister
schönen guten abend haben die bilder
grad schon gesehen aus der
außengastronomie das war so ein ganz
tolles neues lebensgefühl wieder
zumindest hier in berlin zumindest heute
das wetter war ja nicht überall so
richtig tolle am wochenende
wie hat der bundeswirtschaftsminister
die rückkehr der außengastronomie
gefeiert ja es war erstmal eine große
erleichterung nach so wahnsinnig harten
monaten und wochen
ich persönlich konnte überhaupt gar
nicht feiern weil ich vom saarland wo
ich über pfingsten war zurück gefahren
bin über frankfurt und dann nach berlin
zurück und das hat gerechnet dort als
ich in berlin ankam war es ungefähr 18
uhr 30 und da waren aber die cafés und
die außengastronomie waren voll wo man
hat gesehen dass die menschen sich
gefreut haben und darüber freuen wir uns
natürlich genauso denn es ist jetzt auch
an der zeit dass man nachdem die
instanzen gesunken sind schrittweise
auch alle bereiche wie dürfen das heißt
aber sie haben doch gar nicht mitgemacht
oder noch gar nicht mit meinen können
ihr erstes tg erstes schnitzel die erste
bierchen in der außengastronomie steht
noch aus das ist steht noch aus weil ich
heute morgen bei regen im saarland immer
noch haus geblieben bin und dann hat es
geregnet bis wir in frankfurt waren dann
saß ich im flieger und habe dann aber in
berlin gesehen das wetter war schön
die menschen waren auf der straße und
mein eindruck ist im übrigen die meisten
sind noch vorsichtig und halten sich an
die regeln und das ist ja ganz wichtig
damit es dann auch so bleibt und wir
keinen rückschlag
der haken eine außengastronomie ist halt
das wetter wobei ganz ganz viele jahre
mit markisen reagiert haben und große
schirme aufgestellt haben und so weiter
dass wir nicht wieder ein bisschen was
stattfinden kann empfinden sie das nicht
auch ein bisschen als absurd jetzt im
moment das eben viele wieder draußen
sitzen und bier trinken und in
restaurants ihr schnitzel hier wieder
essen während gleichzeitig die schulen
weitestgehend dicht sind beispielsweise
im einzelhandel relativ tote hose ist
man wir haben uns darauf verständigt
dass wir entscheiden nach der situation
vor ort und wir wollen alle dass die
schulen wieder öffnen
aber es muss geklärt werden ob es vor
ort in dem jeweiligen bundesland in dem
jeweiligen landkreis vertretbar ist und
das ist der erste punkt der zweite punkt
ist ich glaube dass wir eine gute chance
haben dass diese dritte werde die letzte
welle war das bedeutet dass wir von
jetzt ab bis zum sommer eine abfolge von
öffnungen erleben werden natürlich mit
der vorlage von tests aber auch mit den
erleichterungen für die geimpften und
für die genesenen natürlich so dass man
abstände watt dass man vieles im freien
veranstaltet was im freien geht aber ich
weiß dass die ersten bundesländer auch
über öffnungen von hotels entschieden
haben dass es auch gedankenspiele gibt
wenn man die innen gastronomie wieder
öffnen kann und solange wir haben sie
die mädels diese gedankenspiele
ich entscheide das ja nicht persönlich
sondern wir machen das und die mieter
gemeinsam ja es kommt ja immer darauf
anderes vertretbar ist und wir haben wir
haben ganz sicherlich möglichkeiten in
vielen restaurants im sommer wenn die
zahlen weiter gesunken sind auch
öffnungen vorzunehmen
aber das hängt dann immer auch davon ab
wie ist die belüftung und kann man davon
ausgehen dass granja aber das wäre
interessant in der luft sind darüber
dass bei regen selbst bei einem
verregneten sommer wir wollen es nicht
hoffen aber selbst an möglichkeiten
bestehen bei gut gehende konzept nur bei
niedrigen zahlen dass es wieder ganzen
jahre schritt schritt für schritt nicht
alles an einem tag aber ich gehe davon
aus dass wir spätestens im monat
september dann auch wieder so etwas wie
halbwegs normalität erreichen können
das muss unser ziel sein und dazu
gehören dann halt eben auch die bereiche
die geschlossen sind es wird sicherlich
dauern bis wieder konzerte mit mehreren
zehntausend teilnehmern möglich sind es
wird sicherlich dauern bis bestimmte
großveranstaltungen genehmigt werden
aber wir können uns dem nähern es wird
sommer konzerte geben können wurden und
menschen mit abstand dann auch verteilt
sind und die musik genießen können ist
ja beim esc jetzt schon gesehen am
wochenende beim eurovision song contest
was man nicht in deutschland sondern bei
den kollegen in rotterdam aber das war
fast befremdlich da hier die schulen
dicht beispielsweise im einzelhandel wie
gesagt auch noch nicht viel los und dann
sieht man da eine großveranstaltung aber
die haben sie in rotterdam nicht mit zur
antwort verantworten wer sind für sie
herr altmaier die korona verlierer und
gewinner verlierer sind wir ganz
sicherlich alle das fängt an bei den
jungen menschen die zum teil monatelang
keine schule hatten oder zumindest
distanz unterricht hatten der aber nicht
in allen fällen so perfekt war wie man
sich das gewünscht hätte es sind
sicherlich auch die verlierer die ihre
ersparnisse ihrer alters rücklagen
aufgebraucht haben um ihre unternehmen
zu retten wir haben 100 milliarden
eingesetzt
alleine zur unterstützung von kleinen
und mittelständischen unternehmen aber
das war natürlich immer noch nicht genug
um alle verluste auszugleichen
um alle nachteile wettzumachen und
deshalb so wie es jetzt aussieht gibt es
ganz ganz viele die sich auch als
verlierer sehen aber wir haben die
chance wieder aufzuholen
und meine hoffnung ist dass wir in
spätestens einem jahr von heute aussagen
dass aus manchem verlierer auch wieder
ein gewinner geworden was manchem oder
aus ganz vielen das wäre mal eine frage
wann würden sie als wirtschaftsminister
sagen perspektive im moment ich weiß
dass es noch schwer zu sagen aber womit
rechnen sie wann diese corona krise
wirtschaftlich überwunden sein
ja wir werden in diesem jahr bereits
einen aufschwung haben aber es wird bis
zum ende des jahres oder bis zum anfang
des nächsten jahres dauern bis wir die
alte wirtschaftliche stärke wieder
erreicht
haben und damit ganz viele zu gewinnen
werden die ganz einfachen und normalen
bürger genauso wie die inhaber von
kleinen und mittleren geschäften
dazu brauchen wir zwei drei jahre lang
ein kräftiges wirtschaftswachstum das
ist aber möglich wir sind zumindest für
dieses jahr und für das nächste jahr
optimistisch dass die wirtschaft
zwischen drei und vier prozent in jedem
jahr wächst und das wäre ein großer
erfolg und darauf arbeiten auch ganz
viele menschen fleißig hin und das zeigt
dass die marktwirtschaftlichen kräfte in
unserem land noch sehr lebendig sind und
die wollen loslegen und die wollen auch
wieder aufholen und nach sind sie
eigentlich auf dem weg dann dafür die
home office schlecht jetzt
schnellstmöglich aufzuheben ja da gibt
es ja sowieso jetzt der lockerungen die
kommen werden weil die verschärfte
version im rahmen der bundes notbremse
in kraft getreten ist die bundes
notbremse wird in vielen bereichen außer
kraft treten
und ich glaube dass das die idee dass
man zur normalität zurückkehrt
sicherlich auch bedeutet dass man dann
dort wo es sinn macht auch wieder vor
ort arbeiten kann
allerdings und das wird so sein glaube
ich dass viele arbeitgeber und viele
arbeitnehmer sich arrangieren werden
flexibler arbeiten werden wir haben auch
positive lektionen gelernt aus dieser
krise und eine von diesen lektionen ist
die flexibilität aber also
freiwilligkeit keine vorschriften ja die
ich dafür weniger vorschriften jahre
schritt für schritt weniger vorschriften
haben gerade über die korona verlierer
gesprochen und ich hatte auch schon über
den einzelhandel gesprochen wo
weitestgehend ja ich sage das jetzt mit
meinen worten noch tote hose herrscht
gemessen zumindest an dem
shoppingerlebnis vorher
jetzt gab es am vergangenen mittwoch vom
kanzleramt demonstrationen protest von
einigen einzelhandelsketten von den
chefs wir sehen hier bilde gerade
eingeblendet vom vergangenen mittwoch
und derweil lief die kabinettssitzung
drin sie waren dann zu der zeit auch
drin im kanzleramt haben sie das mit
eigenen augen eigentlich gesehen dort
den protest
nein ich habe im fernsehen gesehen
anschließend aber mir ist ja sehr
bekannt
die stimmung bei vielen ist wir haben
ich habe ja regelmäßig gespräche mit dem
einzelhandelsverband mit dem hde dem
handelsverband des einzelhandels wir
haben gespräche mit der gastronomie mit
dem restaurant hotel spa zwanziger wird
es da nicht den wirtschaftsminister kurz
vor die tür und sagt man das waren ja
doch gewichtige einzelhandel chefs dass
man dann kurz sagt mensch kommt lasst
uns kurz reden ja eh gegen lärm macht
lasst uns war unterhalten ein aber dafür
hat dafür sind die kontakte eigentlich
zu eng und ich glaube dass das es dann
einfach richtig ist wenn man sich vorher
abspricht und ich wusste von dieser
demonstration ehrlich gesagt nichts im
ford im vorfeld ich glaube auch nicht
dass es um darum geht dass man sich
jovial gibt leuten auf die schulter
klopft denn die probleme sind ja darum
die probleme geht und die leute machen
sich sorgen um ihre unternehmen und ich
als wirtschaftsminister habe mich ins
zeug gelegt seit beginn der korona
pandemie um diesen unternehmen zu helfen
wenn sie sich anschauen was im ersten
lockdown im letzten jahren hilfen
gezahlt wurde und das vergleichen mit
dem was wir jetzt zahlen dann ist es ein
unterschied wie tag und nacht wir haben
diese hilfen ausgeweitet und es hat ja
auch zur folge gehabt dass die große
pleitewelle gottseidank bisher
ausgeblieben ist lassen sie uns mit
einem sprechen der dort mit vom
kanzleramt stand und mit protestiert hat
das ist nämlich patrick zahlen der chef
der einzelhandelskette kick schönen
guten abend herr zahn oder halt mal ja
sagt sie stehen in so gutem austausch
sie kennen ihre gegenseitigen argumente
warum da noch der protest es stimmt wir
mit den alten ein gespräch der protest
kommt daher dafür ein unternehmen die
kik aufgrund der größenordnung in der
unser umsatz sich bewegt bisher keine
hilfen bekommen hat
sprich maximal drei millionen euro pro
monat in summe maximal zwölf millionen
euro da gibt es noch diverse
kleingedrucktes und herr altmaier hat
gerade eben die marktwirtschaftlichen
kräfte angesprochen
die sind unseres erachtens ausgehebelt
wenn der eine händler öffnen darf und
der andere hinter darf nicht öffnen weil
sie nicht ob das noch pandemie bedingt
ist oder nicht das ist ein klarer
eingriff für uns in die marktwirtschaft
und von da ja bei uns der ruf nach
entschädigung weil wir aus
übergeordneten gründen erhalten und auch
das wissen sie dass der einzelhandel
nicht der infektionsherd ist das rki
bestätigt uns dass auch sein mit dem die
türen verschlossen sind bestellt wie das
geht das öffentliche leben still zu
legen und wenn wir dafür herhalten
glaube ich ist der ruf nach
entschädigung auch verständlich also
herr chan möchte natürlich auch ans
gehälter altmaier was sagen sie ihm das
ist ja eine gerechtigkeitsfrage für ihn
das heißt er vertritt die
einzelhandelskette mode kick und leidet
natürlich darunter dass beispielsweise
nebenan der drogerie markt geöffnet hat
und dann eben auch klamotten verkauft
oder in der korona krise noch mehr
klamotten verkauft empfindet das als
ungerecht ja wir haben ja die regelung
dass die geschäfte und die einzelhändler
des täglichen bedarfs geöffnet sind
das sind lebensmittel herren das intro
gerissen und ähnliche und viele von
denen verkaufen seit jahren tag auch
hemden oder t-shirts oder es shorts oder
oder turnschuhe und natürlich ist es
nicht wünschenswert dass es ausgeweitet
wird
auf der anderen seite kann man glaube
ich auch nicht verhindern dass der eine
oder andere der die möglichkeit eben
nicht mehr hat zudem mode händler seines
vertrauens zu gehen sich dann wenn der
milch und käse und fleisch einkauft auch
dort bedient ich verstehe diesen ärger
des einzelhandels und wir haben ja
natürlich viele hilfen für den
einzelhandel auch vorgesehen im rahmen
der überbrückungshilfe drei große
zuschüsse das was ein zahn umtreibt sind
glaube ich zwei dinge das eine ist dass
sein unternehmen eigentlich für die ganz
großen unternehmen wie lufthansa noch
eine stufe zu kleine sein würde die
anderen normalen mittelständischen eine
stufe zu groß ist und er sagt auch die
gastvereine zb die haben die ganzen
hilfen bekommen von ihnen und für ihn
machen sie das portemonnaie aber das
kann das kann ja aufklären
wir hatten in die gastwirtschaft wirte
sind seit dem vierten november des
letzten jahres geschlossen länger als
der einzelhandel länger als jede andere
branche außer diskotheken und
dienstleistungen und wir haben damals
gesagt als wir nur
in anführungszeichen die gastwirte und
die hotels geschlossen haben haben wir
gesagt die bekommen einen teil ihres
umsatzes erstattet dann haben wir ab 15
dezember alle betriebe geschlossen
auch die den einzelhandel bis dahin
offen und dann haben wir gesagt nun gibt
es für alle die überbrückungshilfe und
was man zahlen umtreibt ist dass zwei
wochen lang vom 15 dezember bis zum 31
dezember eben die gastwirte noch die
umsatz erstattung hatten und der
einzelhandel nur ein anfang reichen
überbrückungshilfe aber seitdem sind
alle gleich das wir seit dem ersten
januar werden alle gleich behandelt als
hilfe pro monat und die alleine 13 50
euro mietkosten haben das treibt nicht
um rechtzeitig über 201 kapital bisher
die schließung gekostet haben und ich
habe mal eine frage an sie glauben sie
dass masken gegen das rotavirus helfen
oder nicht im einzelhandel trägt bei
masten sowohl die mitarbeiter als auch
als auch die kunden selber wissen was im
einzelhandel steht dem rk ii wird dass
der einzelhandel dich der infektionsherd
ist wir sind aus über gründen
geschlossen
ich glaube davon aus über geschlossen
ist hat man ein recht auf entschädigung
dazu haben sie haben ja auch nichts
bezahlen müssen sich eine ihnen ich
gönne ihnen jeden euro der hilft
arbeitsplätze und unternehmen zu
erhalten
das ist meine aufgabe als sie wissen
ganz genau dass ich seit wochen als
einziger in brüssel verhandele mit der
europäischen kommission damit man diesen
deckel auf die zwölf millionen nach oben
an hebt das wird dann einigen
unternehmen helfen insbesondere auch dem
ihrigen verhandeln mit dem
bundesfinanzminister über diese fragen
und es sind am ende entscheidungen die
weder der finanzminister noch der
wirtschaftsminister alleine treffen
sondern gemeinsam in 16 bundesländern
gemeinsam mit der gesamten
bundesregierung und diese entscheidungen
stoßen auch auf kritik ja weil es so
unbequeme entscheidungen sind und sie
haben recht der einzelhandel ist nicht
besonders ansteckend aber das gilt für
ganz viele bereiche die wir gestellt
haben und wo die wo die entschädigung in
ähnlicher weise gerät glauben sie wollen
sind dass dieser deckel nach oben weg
fliegt der deckel soll großzügiger
gehandhabt werden ja dafür setze ich
mich ein ich habe das auch ich habe das
auch öffentlich schon vor einiger zeit
gesagt ich möchte im übrigen auch dass
die hilfen weiter gezahlt werden
über den 30 juni hinaus beide vorschläge
liegen dem kollegen olaf scholz vor habe
noch keine antwort erhalten aber ich
gehe davon aus wir werden das in der
bundesregierung auch im sinne von hans
hahn klären und wann diese woche noch
das kann ich das ich weiß nicht also
urlaub scholz hat mich auch sehr viel zu
tun und ich kann eben nur meine
vorschläge schicken wir können
miteinander reden
am rande von kabinettssitzungen aber in
der vergangenheit haben wir uns immer
noch zusammengerauft und wir haben es
geschafft dass inzwischen 100 milliarden
euro ausbezahlt worden sind die hälfte
davon als kredite und die andere hälfte
als zuschüsse die die unternehmen
behalten dürfen damit sie nicht ihr
eigenkapital ganz viel herz an das hat
kein anderes land in europa in dieser
frage auf die reinigung bezahlen
das muss man sauber hat das ist ja hier
und er alt aber wenn ich jetzt einmal
ein mal polemisch sagen kann wenn er
stolze sekunde zeit findet herr zahlen
dann widmet er sich auch ihrem fall
es ist einfach nicht richtig jetzt mal
so im verhältnis getan was gerade
rausgesucht in österreich wo wir sind
verhältnis zum umsatz in österreich
material anzahl das verhältnis zu
deutschland der hilfen eins zu zwölf wir
kriegen also die zwölffache hilfe
österreich es ist nicht richtig länder
wie österreich und malta werden bei den
hilfen gleich behandelt wie deutschland
es ist schlicht wirklich richtig es ist
wohl wahr so die gruppe dieser stadt
fortan steht für 330.000 mitarbeiter in
deutschland das ist eine gigantische
gruppe wie ihr kind oder auch bekannter
schuhhändler et cetera wissen alles in
europa wäre vielleicht nicht den ruf wie
daimler oder bmw aber dass wir völlig
vergessen werden wir helfen nicht
ehrlich ich finde es unglaublich dass
kurzarbeit ordnung sind
wenn wir 100 milliarden für die
deutschen unternehmen und ihre
beschäftigten ohne kurzarbeit
ausgeben das sind steuergelder die wir
ausgeben
dann kann man nicht sagen es wird es
wird einfach alles vergessen und es wird
nichts gemacht
es kann sein dass ihr unternehmen
vielleicht nicht die hilfe bekommt die
es bekommen sollte und aus meiner sicht
auch bekommen könnte ja es gibt aber
andere unternehmen die das ebenfalls
geltend machen die diskotheken in
deutschland
es gibt ganz viele diskotheken in jeder
stadt und in den meisten gemeinden sind
zeit im grunde genommen über einem jahr
geschlossen mit kurzen mit einer kurzen
öffnung im oktober letzten jahres die
leute kommen auch zu mir ich kann denen
keine perspektive geben die großen
konzert veranstalter auch dort arbeiten
zehntausende menschen in deutschland
seit über einem jahr geschlossen
komplett der einzelhandel war immerhin
bis zum 15
bis zum 15 dezember geöffnet und wir
haben ihn doch im märz auch wieder
geöffnet wir haben mit dem was wir was
wir auch mit hilfe der wirtschaft von
ihren verbänden die ich eingeladen hatte
durchgesetzt haben regionalisierte
eröffnungs konzepte
da waren ganz viele einzelne geschäfte
geöffnet und dann sind die instanzen
wieder angestiegen und dann wurden sie
wieder geschlossen und das was ich ihnen
schmeckt sprechen kann ist dass wir
alles tun damit die öffnung die jetzt
kommt eine endgültige ich möchte einen
letzten punkt machen mit ihnen herr
zahlen bitte sie haben ja einen
juristischen weg eingeschlagen bzw
beabsichtigen dies wenn es auch bei den
antworten von herrn altmaier bleibt die
ja nicht darauf zählen dass sie als mit
einem großen geldregen erstmal rechnen
können und völlig zu recht wird ja auch
geprüft was mit unserem steuergeld
ehrlicherweise passiert wer davon
gerettet wird und wer möglicherweise
eben nicht und wer auch so durchkommt
das muss am ende die gerechtigkeitsfrage
sein gehen sie diesen juristischen weg
weg bis zum schluss also natürlich es
kommt es auf kommt darauf an ob es hilfe
gibt und wer oder besser gesagt eine
entschädigung gibt es wird weniger von
hilfen sprechen weil wir halt man ja
gerade auch dargelegt hat im handel
stellt man sich die andere sich bei
diskotheken übrigens anders diskotheken
wenn sie die weiße haus haben was bei
diskotheken normal ist es halt eine
ansteckungsgefahr gegeben es ist im
einzelnen keine ansteckungsgefahr
gegeben
sonst müssten ja alle lebensmittler alle
drogisten schließen weil die mitarbeiter
alle krank sind also diesen gründen
geschlossen mann aus oberhausen
geschlossen ist man recht auf
entschädigung also ich würde es nochmal
sagen ich glaube dass wir einen teil
ihrer anliegen gerecht werden können und
gerecht werden und im übrigen ja wir
sind in deutschland ein rechtsstaat und
wenn man als fan der auffassung ist als
nicht zu 100 prozent und alles was
richtig wäre gemacht wird kann er das
auch vor gericht überprüfen lassen da
habe ich erst recht als minister
verständnis für eine sache klar stellt
mir das wirklich wichtig ist wir
brauchen überhaupt nicht auf volle
entschädigung oder damit das klar ist
wir werden auch nicht klar wenn wir in
einem gewissen maße entschädigt werden
kik hat bisher überhaupt kein geld
bekommen vom staat
das muss man einfach festhalten 19.000
mitarbeiter ist er nicht keine
entschädigung dafür bekommen
kurzarbeitergeld ist eine versicherungs
geschichte also ich würde das muss man
schon klar bin ich auch trennen und auch
darstellen danke herr chan für diese
streitgespräch hier mit dem
bundeswirtschaftsminister wir werden das
weiter verfolgen was da möglicherweise
an entschädigungen oder hilfen noch
fließen wird wie halten sie das
insgesamt mit dem shopping ich finde ja
nach wie vor sehr beschwerlich man macht
es irgendwie nur so wenn es sein muss
gehe ich ganz ehrlich zu mit vorher
testen und jedes mal das ergebnis
vorliegen und dann ist es irgendwie
der maske stunden lang und so weiter wie
man sie ist naja ich hatte ja schon
vorher eigentlich wenig gelegenheit zum
shoppen weil nach 22 uhr die meisten
geschäfte geschlossen hatten
was ich in der korona pandemie getan
habe war mich natürlich darauf zu
konzentrieren dass die
lebensmittelversorgung funktioniert es
ist mir auch gelungen leider wissen zu
viel aber meist mit lieferwagen übrigen
ich freue mich ja ich freue mich darauf
dass es jetzt wieder leichter möglich
wird das erste was ich geschafft habe
das war letzte woche samstag mit einem
gültigen test ein
blumen für meine blumenbeete im garten
das ist jetzt die zeit und ich glaube
und ich freue mich darauf dass ich auch
bei den mode händlern wieder krawatten
kaufen kann dass ich wieder händen
kaufen kann
ja das war mir gesagt dass das
patriotische aufgabe ja natürlich
natürlich ab in den laden mit ihr wollen
wir wollen wir wollen dass diese
geschäfte überlebende wollen dass sie
wieder gute geschäfte machen denn sie
sind teil unserer lebensqualität
das ist das entscheidende wir haben sie
werden sich daran erinnern
vor einiger zeit es ist so rund drei
monate her hier unsere letzte
sonntagabend verabredung gehabt und
hatten damals ja gleichzeitig drei
friseurmeisterin zugeschaltet und wir
wollen uns noch einmal an dieses
aufeinandertreffen von ihnen mit diesen
dreien erinnern
der bundeswirtschaftsminister umgeben
von diesen drei friseurinnen so war es
im bild talk die richtigen fragen am 17
februar renate klinger spur aus münchen
einzel schick aus münster und sabine
klotz aus mannheim
sie alle streiten bei bild mit dem
wirtschaftsminister wann kommen die wann
wird ausgezahlt wann wird uns geholfen
die ihr irgendwelche ergebnisse vor dass
die menschen sich bei den friseuren
angesteckt haben einen herzlichen der
minister er stellt sich all der wut all
der kritik erklärt sich diskutiert
entschuldigt sich
und am ende mussten wir schweren herzens
auch die friseure und auch die
modeboutiquen und die
bekleidungsgeschäfte schließen und dann
gingen die zahlen runter aber nicht weil
sie fehler gemacht hätten sondern weil
weniger menschen auf den straßen
unterwegs waren
ein talk moment der im kopf bleibt
offenbar auch bei minister altmaier
selbst wenige tage später im zdf spricht
altmaier über seine diskussion mit
diesen friseurinnen
ich war neulich bei bild die richtigen
fragen sonntags abends und da bin ich
konfrontiert worden mit vier
friseurmeisterin fast korrekt lieber
herr altmaier
es waren drei nicht vier friseur
meisterinnen doch dann spricht der
minister auch über wirtschaftshilfen die
angeblich teilweise angekommen sein
und dann ist gefragt von haben sie schon
gelder gesehen und haben alle gesagt ja
sie haben schon abschlagszahlungen
gesehen aber es ist noch nicht
ausreichend
doch das stimmt nicht ganz lieber herr
altmaier hier nochmal die wichtigsten
sätze aus ihrem talk auftritt bei bild
anfang februar die finanziellen nöten
sind noch nicht da wir haben 0 1
mit jetzt keine gelder zu beantragen
hier kann nicht ständig über prüfungs
hilfe 2 und die überbrückungshilfe ist
erste beantragen
februar wir werden gar nicht entschädigt
es weiß halt man auch ganz genau
und jetzt sind alle drei
friseurmeisterin noch mal bei uns im
gespräch mit peter altmaier also wenig
links vor aus münchen friseurmeisterin
dort chelsea friseurmeisterin aus
münster beziehungsweise hattingen ganz
dort in der nähe und sabine klotz aus
mannheim schönen guten abend erste frage
natürlich an sie wenn der minister schon
mal wieder da ist netterweise und sich
auch diesem gespräch stellt wie sieht es
denn im moment aus frau klotz bei ihnen
mit hilfen mit geld vom staat haben sie
irgendwas bekommen also als ich das
interview vor drei monaten gesehen habe
als ich sagte wir hatten alle diese
hilfe bekommen habe ich gedacht spruch
im fernseher strenge denn
also ich habe gesagt wir haben keine
hilfen bekommen
und momentan ist es so dass unser
steuerberater dazu geraten hat das
manchmal ab machen soll
weil wir müssen ja unseren umsatz
einschätzen wo ich kann eine ganz klar
frage der mai rote zahlen geschrieben es
war eine nullrunde durchsetze dass hier
in mannheim der inzidenz wert über 100
war und erst die kommende woche jetzt
die testpflicht wegfällt daher ein
kinder friseur sind habe auch in baden
württemberg die täglich für die kinder
gegolten und das sechs jahren war
natürlich total vertan und es war eine
absage nach der anderen
also wir haben noch keine hilfe
beantragt aber jetzt meine frage an sie
bei dem siebzehnten mal kam der
unternehmer die hilfe beantragen
könntest und dann für den unternehmer
lohn können sie mir sagen wie sie auf
die zahl 1000 euro wie man auf ein
unternehmen von 1000 euro komme kam also
ich weiß sie haben gewisse standards und
natürlich die unternehmer haben auf den
standard aber mit 1000 euro
unternehmerlohn also ich kann mir meine
private von bezahlen und wir reden ja
nicht nur von vier was wir ganz kurz
antworten altmaier vorplatz ich glaube
ich glaube man muss man muss zwei dinge
auseinanderhalten das eine ist der
sogenannte unternehmerlohn da geht es um
eine pauschale abgeltung von kosten für
menschen die keine beschäftigten haben
die solo selbständige sind die können
aber natürlich darüber hinaus auch
sozialhilfe beantragen und für ihren
lebensunterhalt für ihre mietkosten und
so weiter das zweite ist die
überbrückungshilfe 3 sie wird gezahlt an
alle unternehmen die einen
umsatzrückgang von mindestens 30 prozent
haben so wie sie es geschildert haben
steht ihnen der anspruch zu da haben sie
aber gesagt sie haben auf rat ihres
beraters noch keinen antrag gestellt
dann können auch die baden
württembergischen behörden natürlich
noch nicht auszahlen und das dritte war
es gab für november und dezember für die
betriebe die geschlossen waren
eine umsatz erstattung von 75 prozent
der ausgefallenen umsätze
und diese hilfen sind inzwischen zu rund
97 prozent ausgezahlt haben wir geklärt
also das bürokratische sozusagen frau
klotz ganz kurz zuvor sell schickt weil
ein punkt wichtig ist nachdem wir über
die hilfen gesprochen haben das ist ja
eine komplex die gute nachricht ist ja
sie alle drei dürfen wieder arbeiten an
das schneller gedurft auch als
gastronomen beispielsweise waren früher
wieder im job als die meisten lehrer das
waren frau selbst deswegen ganz wichtige
frage ob denn überhaupt die kunden
wiederkommen also sind sie so in der
nähe von den umsätzen wieder von beginn
der korona krise oder noch besser vor
der korona krisen abend erst mal alle
zusammen
wir sind ganz bestimmt nicht an unsere
umsätze drangekommen dadurch das ja der
märz war natürlich klasse super aber wir
setzen ja nur die hälfte unserer plätze
viele warten ja trotzdem sehr vorsichtig
wie gesagt die umsätze also haben wir
nicht auf keinen fall kommen wir da ran
frau klinger schon bei ihnen ähnlich in
kalus denen ihr sowieso hat da kommen
wir sowieso nicht dran
also frau klingt zwar bei ihnen ähnlich
oder wird bei ihnen in münchen die bude
eingerannt von kunden also ich wusste
dass wir auf gar keinen fall die
gewinner pandemie zählen erst war sehr
locker und dann kam die testpflicht und
mit der test nicht gegen unsere umsätze
in den keller
und zwar deswegen die kunden hatten
keine lust auf tests und sind einfach
nicht gekommen sie haben alle ihre
termine abgesagt das natürlich ein
riesenproblem wenn das so bliebe harald
meyer vielleicht einmal ganz kurz frau
clouds kurze antwort bitte sie haben ja
so einen speziellen friseursalon haben
sie schon gesagt sie arbeiten vor allen
dingen mit kindern haben dort unter
sechsjährige auch das heißt die mussten
getestet werden die lassen sich nicht so
richtig gerne testen wir sehen hier
einmal den blick in ihren salon da kommt
richtig kleine kunden zu ihnen und das
war für sie natürlich besonders
umständlich sie mussten ordnungsamt
spielen sozusagen bei den ganz kleinen
die zum testen bewegen das hat
vermutlich auch nicht richtig gut
funktioniert immer wie viele tage
arbeiten sie denn im moment sind sie
ausgelastet
also erst nach 70 prozent meiner
kundschaft ist unterwegs
das problem war einfach gewesen in baden
württemberg gilt die test gang die
testpflicht um das sächsische aber in
rheinland-pfalz und in hessen war es
nicht so und da meine kundschaft von
überall her kommt war das ein echtes
problem
im mai war so gewesen und das ist
teilweise in der woche zwei tage
geschlossen hatte
die eltern sagten warum müssen wir ihn
dann noch mal getestet werden wenn sie
schon für die kitas getestet werden wo
auch meine frage ist warum ist es so
vertraut man den eltern nicht oder warum
hat die tests nicht geduldet dass
morgens im kiez die technik und gemacht
bekommen und dann anschließend auch zum
friseur gehen könne
denn ohne test hätten sie ja gar nicht
in die kita könne also warum mussten die
nochmals tab es aus einer text station
bringen
ja da haben sie völlig recht das problem
ganz offenbar war dass diese tests in
der kita und in der schule nicht
bescheinigt wohl anerkannt wird und
damit kann man sie nicht vorlegen und
beweisen dass man getestet wurde
ich habe das alles sehr bedauert ich
meine wir haben schon festgestellt dass
wir in der öffentlichen verwaltung bei
bund ländern und gemeinden gemeinde noch
sehr viel besser werden müssen
es sind menschen zum teil am tag zwei
oder dreimal getestet worden
das hätte man mit digitalen test
nachweis eigentlich viel besser und auch
schneller organisieren entscheidende
frage haltmayer alle drei frau klingt
celtic und frau klotz schildern jetzt
die sind weit entfernt von dem umsatz
den sie sich wünschen den sie auch
gewohnt waren vor der krise
und es ist im moment nicht der richtige
perspektive da war ja testen bleiben
das heißt die müssen üben um ihr
geschäftsmodell bank ganz konkret alle
drei müssen um ihr geschäftsmodell bank
was sagen sie den trend
denen sage ich dass wir dafür sorgen
werden dass sie auch über den 30
juni hinaus überbrückungshilfen bekommen
die voraussetzung ist dass der umsatz
noch 30 prozent unter dem vorjahr liegt
das ist ein drittel weniger umsatz dann
kann man bestimmte fixkosten angeben
dann werden auch andere leistungen
gewährt das wird gemacht
wir diskutieren im augenblick über das
datum bis wann es verlängert wird ich
würde es eigentlich gerne bis ende des
jahres verlängert weil ich weiß dass
viele auch gerade diese tollen geschäfte
und friseursalons eine zeit lang
brauchen um das alles wieder aufzuholen
wir werden das entscheiden und ich sage
ihnen zu wir werden das so lange
fortführen wie es eine nennenswerte zahl
von unternehmen gibt die unter den
spätfolgen von corona nach wie vor
leiden
das heißt folglich spur frau celtic folk
klotzes wird weiter die möglichkeit
geben dann überbrückungshilfen zu
beantragen verspricht der
bundeswirtschaftsminister die frage ist
vielleicht an sie frau sellstedt letzte
frage ob die kunden das tatsächlich nur
wegen des testens im moment nicht machen
dass die weniger zum friseur gehen oder
ob nicht vielmehr in der korona zeit
gemerkt haben eigentlich geht es auch
wenn mir meine schwester oder mein mann
die haare schneidet ich brauche das
eigentlich gar nicht mehr das würde
bedeuten die kombi zurück ja die
verlängern auch ihre termine zeigen weil
sie sind in der korona zeit gehen zwölf
wochen ja auch klar gekommen
natürlich geht den wahrscheinlich
finanziell nicht so gut wie uns und
versuchen sich natürlich so auch über
wasser zu halten
und dann denke ich ja auch keiner an uns
oder eine angststörung oder gut ich habe
einen bestimmten kundenstamm ich bin
auch ganz glücklich und ganz stolz dass
das doch so eben alles klappt wie
gedacht das beste jene konzept was wir
hatten und und weiterhin auch machen
können
mehr geht auch gar nicht und ich teste
aktionen die gedacht wir haben uns hier
werden die sechs mitarbeiter haben und
schulen lassen und haben jetzt auch eine
kleine teststation bei uns aufgebaut
dass unsere kunden nicht noch woanders
hinfahren müssen um sie aufzufangen
diese sorge bleibt die kunden kommen
möglicherweise nie zurück bzw
kommen sie zurück dass das klar ist
glaube ich nicht ist wird sich natürlich
einiges verändern dass leute im internet
bestellen
deshalb müssen wir dafür sorgen dass
auch die einzelhändler im internet
stärker irgendwann frisur gibt aber
sicher gibt es eben die frisur gibt's
nicht im internet und die anlage nicht
optimistisch dass mit unterstützung und
auch das wieder in gang kommt ich
schneide mir die haare seit vielen
jahren selbst aber wenn es dazu helfen
kann da bin ich gerne bereit auch im
saarland noch mal persönlich zum friseur
zu gehen auch wenn der friseur
wahrscheinlich so ganz viel nicht
ausrichten also eher haltmayer fährt
jetzt die ganz große schleife fängt bei
ihnen an am nächsten ist mannheim dran
da geht es rauf nach hattingen und am
ende fahren sie den bogen zu frauen
schon auch eigene frisur sport
linkspartei sind zuerst hat meinen sohn
so gut zum zweiten mal jetzt mit allen
ihnen also haltmayer fertig schleife
nein das müssen sie nicht in wahrheit
allein lösen aber vielleicht ergibt sich
trotzdem eine begegnung in nächster zeit
und vor allen dingen wünschen wir ihnen
dass sie richtig aus der krise
rauskommen und dass die kunden
tatsächlich zu ihnen zurück kommen und
vorher die hilfen von herrn altmaier
herzlichen dank ihnen drei nach mannheim
nach münchen und nach hattingen danke
herzlich
letzte frage altmaier wir müssen einmal
kurz über große weltpolitik sprechen
ein thema das uns ganz wahnsinnig bewegt
seit gestern ist dass der weißrussische
präsident ein flugzeug ja vom himmel
geholt hat muss man sagen ein ryanair
urlaubsflieger um dort einen ungeliebten
oppositionellen einfach raus zu
schnappen und das mitten in europa ja
das ist ein ganz unerhörter vorgang von
luft piraterie und es ist eine flagrante
verletzung von menschenrechten
die verletzung von völkerrecht eine
verletzung von menschenrechten das darf
nicht durchgehen
ich mache mir große sorgen um die
unversehrtheit von roman prokoph savage
und deshalb hoffe ich lehre in einem
krankenhaus befinden soll angeht ja zu
der zeit jetzt hört deshalb ja und
deshalb hoffe ich und deshalb hoffe ich
dass die staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen
union die zu diesem zeitpunkt genau
darüber sprechen
ein starkes signal senden dass wir das
nicht akzeptieren werden das für
konkrete maßnahmen ergreifen was ein
starkes signal können sie das
konkretisieren weil meine befürchtung
ist dass das signal zu schwach ausfällt
so langsam wie wir oft die europäische
union und so zögerlich wie wir oft die
europäische union in letzter zeit
wahrnehmen
ja wir haben ja schon bei den protesten
vor einigen monaten sanktionen verhängt
ich glaube das ist jetzt vor allen
dingen darum geht zu verhindern dass
weitere flugzeuge gekapert werden also
überflugverbot auch für europäische
flüge über weißrussland zweitens muss
man darüber reden inwieweit landerechte
für weißrussische flugzeuge in europa
ausgesetzt konzern gerade auch so
heitmeyer das ist ganz da ist es ganz
frisch und nicht inszeniert ist und
haben diesen minuten geht es gerade über
die agentur dass genau das beschlossen
wurde überflugverbot für weißrussische
flieger über europäischen luftraum
ich halte das für absolut notwendig und
richtig das ist eine maßnahme die sehr
spürbare folgen haben wird nicht nur für
die fluggesellschaft von weißrussland
sondern auch für das land und vor allen
dingen ich glaube lukaschenko muss
wissen wenn wenn er nicht garantiert
dass die unversehrtheit dieses jungen
regimekritikers der nichts anderes getan
hat als mit schrift und wort demokratie
und menschenrechte einzufordern dass wir
ihnen dafür auch persönlich
verantwortlich machen und in und
möglicherweise auch den russischen
präsidenten ist es ganz schwer zu fassen
da ist lukaschenko das ohne wissens ja
vielmehr eine enge abstimmung mit
flatrate ist ja bekannt ist ja bekannt
dass weißrussland und auch russland in
diesen menschenrechtsfragen zum teil eng
zusammenarbeiten
trotzdem muss man mit allgemeinen
schlossen vorsichtig sein
ich habe festgestellt jedenfalls dass
sich die lage in weißrussland einem
halben jahr drastisch verschlechtert hat
und sich immer weiter verschlechtert und
das dürfen wir nicht hinnehmen und
deshalb
brauchen wir jetzt eine klare antwort
und das ist kräuter abend der erste
schritt und ich glaube dass wir da auf
gar keinen fall nachlässig oder werden
dürfen oder wegschauen dürfen das ist
eine frage von grundsätzlicher bedeutung
denn das würde uns zum bäcker machen
alle in der eu herzlichen dank peter
altmaier der bundeswirtschaftsminister
für das gespräch hier über diese
dramatischen vorfälle in weißrussland wo
ein ryanair flieger vom himmel geholt
wurde vor allen dingen aber über das
thema corona wirtschaft wir haben über
corona verlierer gesprochen werde über
den einzelhandel gesprochen wir haben
mit friseurinnen gesprochen und wir
haben über das thema schule gesprochen
und dieses thema wollen wir noch einmal
weiter vertiefen denn da sprechen wir
über kroner verlierer das wollen wir tun
mit ihrer kabinettskollegin anja
karliczek und wollen uns noch einmal die
gegebenen versprechen der
bundesregierung mit blick auf die
deutschen schüler und schülerinnen
anschauen schule first das war das große
versprechen der bundesregierung für
niemanden wird er locker und kürzer sein
als für schüler und schülerinnen
das ist das letzte was wir schließen und
das ist das erste was wir öffnen bildung
hat priorität und dabei bleibt so
versprochen gebrochen
mehr als fünf monate nach diesen sätzen
des kanzleramtsministers gibt es fast
überall in deutschland noch keine
normalen schulunterricht sondern
hunderte ausgefallene schulstunden
wechsel unterricht so sieht es derzeit
fast überall im klassenzimmer aus immer
noch und so sieht im urlaubsflieger aus
und so in der gastronomie bilder die elf
millionen schülern und deren eltern
nicht mehr zu erklären sind nach all den
versprechen wie diesen
wir setzen alles daran kitas und schulen
als erstes wieder öffnen zu können um
den kindern und familien ein stück ihres
gewohnten alltags wiederzugeben
darüber müssen wir reden jetzt mit der
bundesbildungsministerin mit anja
karliczek schönen guten abend frau karla
check all diese beteuerung all diese
sätze schule hat absolute priorität das
ist das erste was wir wieder öffnen
werden die waren nichts wert
bildung möglich zu machen hat nach wie
vor sehr sehr hohe priorität deswegen
haben wir ja im letzten sommer schon die
länder auch sehr stark unterstützt den
distanz unterricht zu verbessern
aber nichtsdestotrotz alles in einem bis
präsenzunterricht durch nichts zu
ersetzen und wir müssen jetzt angesichts
der abflachenden infektionen doch
schritt für schritt wieder auch zu
präsenzunterricht zumindest erstmal zum
wechsel unterricht zurückkehren
in der tat aber es gibt ja da ein ganz
klar gegebenes versprechen wir haben das
gerade gehört von kanzleramtschef von
der kanzlerin persönlich sie haben sich
genauso geäußert ich ganze ministerriege
hat das gesagt schulen haben absolute
priorität das ist das was wir als letzte
schließen und als erstes öffnen wir
müssen ja einmal festhalten heute das
ist nicht passiert
naja die notbremse hat ja genau das eben
so vorgesehen dass wir eine höhere
intelligenz fall haben für schulen
schließen und eben die bands darunter
geht noch bevor eben alle anderen wieder
aufmachen können kann man auch mit den
schulen schon wieder in den wechsel
unterricht gehen
nichtsdestotrotz sind wir natürlich
immer in einer situation der
gratwanderung wie viel bildung können
wir möglich machen und wie viel
gesundheitsschutz müssen wir eben auch
möglich machen denn der schutz der
gesundheit der kinder ist natürlich auch
ein hohes gut aber ich will jetzt in
fast allen ländern das schritt für
schritt doch zum präsenzunterricht
wieder zurückgekehrt wird aber frau
karla check noch einmal ganz kurz
festgehalten sozusagen fürs protokoll
das was man versprochen hat das hat man
nicht erfüllt zuerst die schulen öffnen
ich meine jetzt ja gerne ganz einfache
feststellung wir gucken um uns herum die
gastronomie macht wieder auf die
friseure haben lange geöffnet geschäfte
haben wieder geöffnet wenn auch unter
bestimmten voraussetzung aber die
schulen haben in weiten teilen noch
geschlossen es gibt keinen
präsenzunterricht und wenn dann nur
wechsel unterricht das heißt dieses
versprechen ist nicht eingehalten
na ja wir haben zum einen gesehen dass
im laufe dieses jahres auch in dem
distanz unterricht einige verbesserungen
stattgefunden haben und im moment läuft
ja alles sehr parallel auch das muss man
ja auch anerkennen und wichtig ist doch
und das finde ich sollten wir den
mittelpunkt stellen dass wir alles dafür
tun dass wir jetzt schritt für schritt
zum normalen präsenzunterricht
zurückkehren können auch möglichst noch
vor den ferien
auch einige bundesländer die auch noch
bis weit in den juli in die schule gehen
müssen und dass wir eben trotzdem dafür
sorgen dass wir mit guten ideen
konzepten und guten test strategien
diesen präsenzunterricht dann auch
halten können das ist ja unsere große
sorge im moment dass wir angesichts der
schnellen und vielen öffnungen die wir
in einen bereichen sehen dass wir genau
da wieder in die situation kommen dass
wir eben diese guten oder sinkenden
inzidenz zahlen an der stelle nicht
halten können wichtig ist dass wir eben
dann auch wieder eine sehr hohe
priorität auf die bildung setzen so dass
wir da weiter präsenzunterricht möglich
machen können und ich will schon dass
wir schritt für schritt wirklich zum
präsenzunterricht in den meisten
bundesländern zur rückkehr ja das stimmt
aber es geht ja um die reihenfolge und
genau das ist nicht eingehalten ich
werde solange nachfragten plötzlich eine
antwort bekommen wir von kali zeigt weil
das ist wirklich wichtig sie haben das
versprochen wir haben die zitate gerade
noch mal gehört von kanzleramtschef und
von der kanzlerin
zuerst die schulen das ist nicht
passiert
ja wir haben im winter bevor weg oder
als wir schließen mussten haben wir aber
gesehen dass wir in wenigen ganz kurzer
zeit november dezember januar hatten wir
50.000 tod wir haben also wirklich
massive zahlenden infektionen gesehen
und diese infektionen haben in einem
nachholeffekt auch in den schulen
stattgefunden und auch in den kitas und
finden nach wie vor dort statt wir sehen
im moment infektionszahlen gerade bei
den jüngeren kindern und dass wir immer
wieder das thema bildung und
bildungsmöglichkeiten schaffen und
trotzdem gesundheitsschutz abzuwägen
das ist doch das was uns jetzt seit über
einem jahr alle miteinander umtreibt und
ich kann ja die sorge verstehen dass
eltern sagen ja wir wollen dass die
bildungseinrichtungen wieder aufmachen
aber ich sehe auch die eltern die mir
sagen ihr könnt mein kind noch nicht in
die schule schicken wenn die
infektionszahlen so hoch sind aber dass
immer wieder bewegen habe stimme aber
jetzt sie haben es gerade in der
vorherige antwort auf meine immer
gleiche frage schon versteckt gehabt sie
haben nämlich gesagt dass wir jetzt
anhand der anderen öffnungen wieder
gucken müssen dass wir es nicht
übertreiben so das nicht möglicherweise
schulen dann noch länger geschlossen
werden und genau das haben sie im
kabinett ja schon vorausgesehen und
haben genau deswegen gesagt deswegen
müssen wir die schulen zuerst
eröffnen damit nicht genau dieser effekt
entsteht damit wir nicht genau lockern
den anderen bereichen und dann
möglicherweise schüler und schülerinnen
noch länger zu hause bleiben müssen aber
genau das genau das passiert jetzt
herr weise wir sehen das im moment die
dinge parallel laufen und die dinge
laufen parallel
weil natürlich in allen bereichen jetzt
ein hoher druck da ist mit guten test
konzepten guten strategien und auf einem
immer weiter fortschreitenden impfen
auch immer mehr möglich machen zu können
und dass wir jetzt eben zum
präsenzunterricht schritt für schritt
zurückgehen das ist doch genau die
botschaft die jetzt alle brauchen dass
wir schritt für schritt in einen
bereichen zu einem normalen geschehen
zurück kommen und dass wir für den
herbst auch in der lage sind normalen
schulbetrieb auf jeden fall nach den
ferien wieder möglich zu machen
das ist halt ein wahnsinnig langer
zeitraum und wir haben diese zitate
gerade eingespielt von kanzleramtschef
das ist aus dem dezember da der im
dezember gesagt das erste was wir wieder
öffnen versprochen sind die schulen und
im januar die kanzlerin nachgelegt und
hat gesagt absolute priorität wir gucken
genau wie lange der lok down gehen muss
und sobald es wieder möglich ist
absoluter priorität haben die schulen
sie haben es nicht eingehalten es wäre
an der zeit sich dafür bei meiner
ansicht nach bei schülern und auch ganz
ganz vielen eltern zu entschuldigen dass
man von dieser reihenfolge die total
vernünftig war abgewichen ist
na ja wir haben halt auch gesehen dass
immer wieder das infektionsgeschehen
gerade bei den jüngeren sehr sehr hoch
war und das ist doch das wesen einer
pandemie gewesen das wesen dieses
letzten jahres dass wir uns immer wieder
die lage angeguckt haben und immer
wieder auf die lage so reagiert haben
wie wir glauben dass es der richtige weg
ist dass wir es verantworten können es
gibt immer den punkt an dem man streiten
kann hat man das eingehalten was man
versprochen hat aber wichtig ist doch
dass wir gesundheitsschutz und
möglichkeiten für bildung so gut es geht
immer wieder in einklang bringen bringen
wolken bringen wollen und auch bringen
werden
vor dem hintergrund ist ja zum beispiel
auch jetzt die frage aufgekommen gibt es
eigentlich auch andere
gesundheitsschäden die vielleicht
genauso relevant sind und die vielleicht
an den fokus auch noch mal anders
ich sag mal auf eine andere auf eine
andere situation lenken und das ist doch
das gewesen wo wir damals gesagt an
präsenzunterricht hat eine hohe
priorität und dazu wollen wir jetzt auf
jeden fall auch vor den ferien noch mal
zurückkommen und wir streiten ja ehefrau
karla checker bei eines finde ich total
unstrittig nämlich dass das versprechen
nicht eingehalten wurde das liegt ja
jetzt auf der hand also wir haben ja
jetzt am pfingstwochenende gesehen da
musste man nicht allzu genau hingucken
man hat halt gesehen dass restaurants
außen wieder voll sind das kneippen
außen wieder voll sind das cafés außen
wieder voll sind und dass man eben diese
priorisierung schulen first nicht
eingehalten hat naja aber schulen sind
eben nicht nur bildungseinrichtungen
schulen sind eben auch möglichkeiten
sich zu treffen im team zu arbeiten das
ist für kinder übrigens auch ganz
wichtig mit gleichaltrigen zusammen zu
sein das kann ja vielleicht auch in der
einen oder anderen form gerade auch in
einer kleineren gruppe dann genauso
außerhalb der schule stattfinden das ist
doch der punkt den wir jetzt auch in den
fokus nehmen dass es eben nicht mehr nur
um die frage wieviel schule machen wir
jetzt jetzt und hier sofort wieder
möglich sondern gibt es eben jetzt auch
konzepte überhaupt das treffen von
jungen menschen wieder möglich zu machen
deswegen haben wir übrigens unser 2
milliarden programm gemacht dass wir
eben jetzt auch die soziale komponente
stark in den mittelpunkt aber noch mal
ganz kurz was sind dann diese
versprechungen die kann man jetzt nicht
von irgendwem die kamen auch von ihnen
aber wir haben es jetzt gezeigt von
kanzleramtschef und von der kanzlerin
das heißt viel höher geht es im grunde
nicht beide haben dasselbe versprechen
abgegeben beide miteinander abgestimmt
beide davon völlig überzeugt was ist
dann so ein versprechen wert wenn es
monate später ist na gut könnte halt
auch immer anders kommen lieber herr
weise ich haben gerade gesagt das
wichtige ist doch dass wir in einer
pandemie auf eine aktuelle lage
reagieren und wir haben eben gesehen
dass die infektionszahlen gerade bei den
jüngeren in der letzten zeit sehr sehr
hoch war und dass wir dann darauf
reagieren und dass wir dann eben gucken
müssen wie kann man denn überhaupt den
unterricht in so einer situation wieder
möglich machen wie kann man schule
gerade in der schule treffen sich sehr
viele menschen auf sehr engem raum wie
kann man das überhaupt möglich machen
vor allen dingen vor dem hintergrund
dass man dort noch nicht impfen kann
solange noch kein impfstoff jovan
indirekt so levine in den schulen anhand
derer man dann entschieden hat das
versprechen nicht einzuhalten
man hat gesehen dass ihm das in den in
diesen einzelnen alterskohorten der
nachholeffekt so war dass die pandemie
sich gleichmäßig über alle alters-
generationen ausbreitet und da wir eben
in dem bereich noch nicht impfen können
müssen wir eben in dem bereich jetzt
dafür sorgen dass wir andere sichere
konzepte haben dass das
infektionsgeschehen jetzt nachlässt das
gibt uns doch ganz neue möglichkeiten
und die länder reagieren ja gerade
darauf indem sie ganz klar die
perspektive geben in den schulunterricht
in den präsenzunterricht wieder
zurückzukehren
was mich immer wundert nicht nur bei
ihnen frau carlitscheck im moment ist so
ein spin irgendwie dass alle sagen schon
vor den sommerferien oder schon direkt
nach den sommerferien könnten wir
eventuell wieder normalen
präsenzunterricht anbieten ich kenne
keinen einzigen vater keine einzige mama
in diesem land der das als schön
empfindet er das so empfindet als wäre
das jetzt doch relativ schnell dass man
wieder im präsenzunterricht geht wir
wollen einmal amelie zu schalten
die aus münchen mit uns spricht die
sieben jahre alt hallo ich sehe die
schau neben dir die
bundesbildungsministerin anja karliczek
du kennst ich glaube ich hast du mir
vorher verraten und amelie ist im
vergangenen sommer eingeschult worden
vielleicht kannst du noch mal ganz kurz
erzählen wie das war für dich in die
schule zu kommen
mit jack einer richtigen
einschulungsfeier wie lief das ab war
das ein bisschen traurig
[Musik]
diesen das lied für mich so richtig ein
tag aus und ja das war also im letzten
august an ich kann das ganz gut
nachvollziehen meine kleine tochter ist
auch eingeschult worden im august da
ging das ganz genauso
auch keine einschulungsfeier usw wie
läuft es jetzt bei dir amélie hast du
wieder ja einigermaßen normalen
unterricht wie viel wie viel stunden
läuft das im moment bei dir nur zwei
stunden zwei stunden am tag im moment
und das ist geht ja immer ganz schnell
wieder vorbei dass die dass man gerade
sich hingesetzt hat sozusagen und dann
ist der unterricht schon wieder gelaufen
hast du das gefühl dass du ja ganz gut
lernen kannst in der schule dass das gut
organisiert ist wie es dein gefühl dazu
unser buch fertig und wieder ja es geht
ja auch natürlich um freunde treffen
aber auch um lesen und schreiben
klappt das da richtig gut oder ist das
schwierig wenn man das auch ja vor allen
dingen mit denen mit den eltern
natürlich zu hause
nachmittags noch pauken muss versteht
dann winterschäden verstehen sagt mehr
richtig ab und das gehe und dass die
kinder dann verstehen aber zu hause ist
es dann so schwer
zum beispiel dort wo man dann sichtbar
eine stunde lang von 1000 sterne noch
gar nichts gedacht und überlegt sein
papa sitzt neben dir und weiß das
natürlich auch wie homeschooling
funktioniert das natürlich braucht man
jemanden der auch mal rüber guckt über
die schultern und einem noch mal ein
ratschlag gibt und es können eben nicht
nur die eltern seien lokale check ist ja
klar ich will ihnen beiden frau karin
und amelie nochmal zwei fotos zeigen die
finde ich so bezeichnet sind im moment
nämlich so wie es im moment in
klassenräumen eben aussieht auch bei
amelie da sitzen alle weit auseinander
die schüler getrennt mit masken
natürlich und eben auf abstand und so
sieht es aktuell im urlaubsflieger aus
dicht beisammen volle urlaubsflieger
amerika man das kapieren warum die im
flugzeug auf dem weg im urlaub so dicht
sitzen können und im klassenzimmer halt
nicht
ich kann so ehrlich gesagt auch nicht
erklären ich kapiere so nicht kapieren
sie ist contis erklärt
sie haben ganz unterschiedliche
situationen diese miteinander
vergleichen denn ich glaube auch die
fluglinien die jetzt solche flüge
anbieten haben ein großes interesse
daran in ihrem flieger keine
infektionsgeschehen zu verbreiten im
öffentlichen raum und auch in schulen
was der öffentliche einrichtungen sind
ist es natürlich geboten das mit
sicheren konzepten bei kindern lieber
heute noch nicht impfen können
letztendlich auch erst einmal sicherer
schulunterricht geboten ist und von
daher ist es schon wichtig dass sie wenn
sie solche fotos zeigen eigentlich auch
zeigen dass viele sich jetzt gut
eingerichtet haben mit
gute hygiene konzept und ich hoffe auch
einer guten test strategie sicheren
schulunterricht erstmal möglich zu
machen so können auch erstmal kinder
wieder zusammenkommen und das ist doch
jetzt mal der wichtigste punkt also
finden sie das nicht gerecht im
vergleich finden total gerecht weil
hygiene konzepte in schulen gibt es ja
teilweise aber die müssen halt trotzdem
im wechsel unterricht bleiben das heißt
da bleiben wie sie ja noch viel besser
wissen die schüler halt einfach zu hause
aber im urlaubsflieger sitzen die dicht
gedrängt auf weg auf die kanaren meint
wege oder nach mallorca dann die zwei
drei stunden oder auf die kanaren 67
stunden dicht gedrängt zusammen gibt es
für mich ehrlich gesagt keinen
unterschied
naja es ist doch einfach mal klar dass
wir auf jeden fall jetzt so viel
normalität wie möglich in allen
bereichen möglich machen wollen dass wir
sichere strategien brauchen
und je mehr menschen geimpft sind umso
einfacher ist es eben auch zu ganz viel
normalität zurückzukommen ich finde wir
sollten in dieser situation nicht die
einzigen branche und die einzelnen
bereiche in der gesellschaft
gegeneinander ausspielen wir sollten
alles dafür tun dass das
infektionsgeschehen so niedrig gehalten
wird wie möglich und das wir dass wir
unsere kinder besten wirklich schützen
wollen das ist doch wohl unsere
kernaufgabe und ich glaube da haben sich
jetzt gerade die schulen auch sehr gut
arrangiert und eingerichtet so gut wie
es ihnen möglich ist
danke dafür amelie magst du noch eine
letzte sache der bildungsministerin
sagen ja nix los also in sachsen
das ist nicht so gefährlich wie in
bayern sagte mitschek ich habe die
amélie leider überhaupt nicht verstehen
und sein hat das noch mal sagt in
sachsen in sachsen muss man das weiß sie
aus der familie
da muss man keine maske mehr tragen im
schulunterricht aber amélie muss sind
bayern noch die maske tragen und will
wissen warum das so ist
naja das eine ist dass das
infektionsgeschehen sehr unterschiedlich
ist in den regionen und das zweite ist
dass die entscheidungen wie der
unterricht stattfindet und was für regen
dort gelten auch bundesländer
unterschiedlich stattfindet ich glaube
das ist manchmal nicht so ganz einfach
zu verstehen aber lieber ami ich hoffe
wir kommen alle gemeinsamen dadurch so
dass dann fürs zweite schuljahr doch
wieder alles ziemlich normal stattfinden
kann
dass die antwort von der
bundesbildungsministerin amélie ehrlich
gesagt finde ich super ab und zu genau
diese einfachen fragen zu stellen weil
das zeigt manchmal dass es gar keine
erklärungen gibt und entscheidungen für
die es keine erklärung gibt sind
wahrscheinlich meistens keine guten
entscheidungen also ich glaube auch dass
die lage in sachsen nicht so viel anders
als in bayern und wünsche dir und allen
anderen kindern im lande sie so schnell
die maske wieder abnehmen kann wie
können wie nur irgend möglich im
schulunterricht danke amelie dass du das
heute abend mit uns gemacht hast liebe
grüße nach münchen
ja danke für deinen mut wir wollen die
runde noch einmal erweitern und wollen
dazu holen ihr herz birgit kelle die mit
uns streitet ebenso dario schramm der
generalsekretär der
bundesschülerkonferenz ist und diesem
jahr sein abitur bauen möchte also
wirklich noch großes vor sich hat und
kathrin krause die ärztin ist aber vor
allen dingen auch mutter ist sie hat
eine tochter die gerade in die vierte
klasse geht neun jahre alt ist in allen
schönen guten abend im keller wir haben
gerade darüber gestritten über diesen
vergleich einerseits volle
urlaubsflieger andererseits weiterhin
wechsel unterricht und die ministerin
hat gesagt na ja so ganz vergleichen
lässt sich das nicht ein bisschen
ungerecht der vergleich ich finde nach
wie vor total treffen und ich glaube
dass das kein kind und keine eltern zu
vermitteln ist warum einerseits die
menschen dicht gedrängt den urlaub
fliegen und auf der andererseits auf der
anderen seite immer noch so weit
entfernt sitzen möchte müssen dass man
wechsel unterricht nur anbieten kann
ich sehe das ähnlich ich suche auch nach
einer erklärung und ich diskutiere das
auch mit meinen kindern
jetzt schon sagen über einem jahr weil
ich es meinen kindern auch nicht
erklären können und ich im übrigen auch
eine erklärung von der schule verlangt
habe auch dort habe ich keine bekommen
es ist doch so wir haben ich bin selbst
auch einsteck anforderung das heißt ich
da fliegen beruflich meine kinder sitzen
im wechsel unterricht also ich habe zwei
kinder noch in der schule zwei kinder in
der ausbildung ein sohn der letztes jahr
auch kein abi ball hatte und der noch
auf den start seiner ausbildung wartet
alles wegen krone und gleichzeitig
erlebe ich dass es eben jetzt schon seit
16 monaten wir eine pandemie haben die
versprechungen nicht eingehalten werden
und es vor allen dingen auch kein
konzept gibt und dieses geöffneten doch
oder wir machen vor den sommerferien
irgendwas möglich also es ist in der tat
so man kann es als eltern eigentlich
nicht mehr hören man kann es nicht mehr
erklären es faktisch würde ich jetzt mal
sagen haben fast alle kinder mindestens
ein halbes jahr schule eigentlich
komplett verloren in diesem land und ich
fand im mini sehr tapfer die gerade zu
uns gesprochen hat wir machen gerade die
kleinen kinder noch viel mehr sorgen als
die älteren also meine jüngste die es
fast 13
die hat schon gelernt eigenständig zu
lernen da funktioniert dass ein vater
mit dem lernen zu hause weil die kinder
schon etwas strukturierter sind aber je
jünger sie sind umso schwieriger wird es
in behandlung millionen kinder die einen
schlechten start in die schule bekommen
die also schon das lesen und schreiben
lernen oder also die grundzüge
mathematik alles einen schlechten start
haben da mache ich mir um die
bildungskarriere durchaus gedanken
allerdings würde ich auch dafür
plädieren zu sagen wir dürfen nicht nur
die schule sehen wir dürfen nicht immer
nur in der schule denken die kinder das
leben der kinder findet nicht nur in der
schule statt sondern wir beschneiden
ihnen auch weitestgehend sonst ihr leben
meine kinder haben auch keinen sport und
kein keine sport vor einem jahr keine
musikschule mehr keine
freizeitmöglichkeiten wir haben hier in
nrw städte da muss man sich anmelden für
den spielplatz einen termin geben lassen
wir haben bürgermeister die schütten dem
skateplatz zu damit die jungs nicht
geben können und schütten der kies drauf
und solche geschichten wir auch in einer
ganzen kinder generation er auch viel
lebenswirklichkeit bildung ist ja nicht
einfach nur lesen schreiben rechnen
sondern es geht darum dass die menschen
werden sollen dass sie dass sie wechseln
sollen am leben das sie erfahrungen
sammeln und das geht alles verloren und
dann ging es schon viel und vielleicht
kann ich da eine frage in den raum
stellen die meine zwölfjährige stellen
würde nämlich die frage warum sie
eigentlich nicht badminton trainieren
darf in ihrem verein wo sie nur zwei
menschen stehen würde gegenüber an einem
netz und sie darf nicht trainieren aber
die bundesliga trainieren
naja also erstmal glaube ich teilt uns
die sorge was in diesem jahr jetzt alles
auf der strecke geblieben ist weil es
ist ja eben nicht nur lernen sondern es
ist ja eben auch zum beispiel der sport
in frau keller angesprochen hat da ist
natürlich auch vieles nicht möglich
gewesen gerade die ballsportarten die
man im team spielt aber kontaktloser
sport ist ja jetzt mit sinkendem
infektionsgeschehen schritt für schritt
in den bundesländern auch wieder erlaubt
und ich glaube wir müssen jetzt im
nächsten schritt auch hingucken wie kann
man zum beispiel auch über kontaktlos
gerade auch bei teamsportarten trotzdem
ein wenig gemeinschaft möglich machen am
ende wird es noch nicht so sein dass wir
alle ballsportarten gerade die wo man
eben auch vielleicht eng miteinander
spielt sofort möglich machen können aber
auch da wird es jetzt schritt für
schritt erleichterungen geben wir wollen
noch und das ist doch das was uns eint
wir wollen doch dass ich möglichst wenig
menschen anstecken und dass wir schritt
für schritt so möglichst viel normalität
wieder zurückkehren und die liebe frau
kelly genau das war ja das was uns
bewegt hat dass wir gesagt haben wir
wollen einfach nach diesem sommer doch
ziemlich deprimierend
denn jahr für viele kinder einfach auch
wieder jetzt nachholen möglich machen
nachholen auf der einen seite bei den
lern rückständen und auf der anderen
seite bei dem was eben auch an
persönlichkeitsentwicklung und auch
sozialen miteinander auf der strecke
geblieben ist wir wissen doch um das was
da passiert ist wir sehen doch auch das
im grunde die kinder jetzt etwas
nachholen wollen
und jetzt muss man halt gucken das wort
bei allem wunsch das war etwas nachholen
wollen und dass wir eben auch möglich
was möglich machen wollen gerade für die
kinder dürfen wir eins nicht aus dem
auge verlieren unsere impfkampagne nimmt
an fahrt zu aber eben auch gerade kinder
moment unter 16 und unter 12 bekommen
wir auch noch eine weile bleiben wir
gleich noch martin auf den neuen
ansteckungen
da kommen wir gleich noch mal darauf zu
sprechen von kali steckt das was sie in
dieser sendung machen ist ja immer sagen
mensch lasst uns zusammen nach vorne
gucken aber das verständnis vieler
schüler und eltern dafür jetzt weiter
zusammen durch diese krise zu gehen das
ist ein bisschen gemindert angesichts
dessen dass eben auch wir haben das zu
beginn dieser sendung gesagt immer
wieder auch versprechen nicht
eingehalten wäre wurden oder nicht
werden konnten herr schreiben sie machen
in diesem jahr abitur was ist das für
eine lasters im corona ja zu machen ja
ich meine das abitur als ähnlich wie
alle anderen abschlüsse die große sorge
gewesen wie gut dass man vorbereitet
aber vielleicht um ganz kurz diese
dieser anfangs frage nämlich die frage
der bildung und schülerinnen und schüler
oberste priorität frage da komme ich
natürlich nicht warum das auch noch mal
ganz kalten finger in die wunde zu legen
denn das ist das problem was wenn er in
der schule jetzt seit eineinhalb jahren
erlebt haben viele in der politik haben
versprochen wir sind die oberste
priorität das war immer wieder dieser
ist durch es geht dann aber wieder
besser weiter und wir haben das jetzt
ganz klar erlebt also man muss nur auf
die straße gehen sie haben es
angesprochen und jedem menschen wird
klar es war eben nicht oberste priorität
und da muss man ehrlich sein weil das
führt einfach zur frustration am ende
deswegen noch einmal die gelegenheit
vielleicht frau carlitscheck man könnte
wir haben das bei anderen punkten erlebt
in den vergangenen wochen dass man
fehler machen kann auch in einer solchen
pandemie und dass man dann auch
irgendwann sagen kann okay leute das war
falsch dass es hier schlecht gelaufen
sorry entschuldigung und jetzt geht es
weiter und jetzt versuchen wir diesen
fehler wieder gut zu machen das heißt
die gelegenheit sich dafür zu
entschuldigen
die frage ist ja entschuldigen oder muss
man nicht einfach gucken wir waren zum
beispiel auf die frage von distanz
unterricht ja überhaupt nicht gut
vorbereitet das war aber eine situation
die wir versucht haben im laufe des
letzten jahres ein stück weit zu heilen
nachzuholen wo es so schnell nachzuholen
geht dass wir uns im bereich der die
gibt es die der digitalen schule wenn
wir viel weiter gewesen wären uns ganz
andere möglichkeiten hätten mehr
arbeiten können ich glaube das
bestreitet auch niemand aber dass wir in
einer
so unsicheren situation immer wieder
bildungsmöglichkeiten gegen
gesundheitsschutz abgewogen haben und
uns dann auch mal unterschiedlich
entschieden haben ich glaube das ist
etwas das ist nicht ich sage mal einen
fehler in einer klassischen form gewesen
sondern einfach auch der situation einer
sehr unsicheren situation in dieser form
geschuldet gewesen und ich finde schon
dass wir gemeinschaftlich zwischen bund
und ländern auch in den
unterschiedlichen zuständigkeiten alles
dafür getan haben so viel wie möglich
doch zuzulassen aber am ende ist es auch
so dass wir alle miteinander eine
pandemie doch noch nicht erlebt haben
und ich bin schon dafür dass auch diese
diskussion jung gegen alt jetzt häufig
auf gemacht wird dass das eigentlich ein
falscher fokus ist natürlich geht es
erstmal darum tote zu verhindern und
unser gesundheitssystem in der lage zu
halten dass wir immer helfen können und
jetzt geht es darum eben für die jungen
menschen auch den fokus darauf zu legen
was können wir für sie möglich machen
und der herr schramm gerade diese frage
abschlussklassen die abschlüsse auch in
einen in einer relativ gewohnten form
möglich zu machen da haben wir von
vornherein den fokus gehe ich gerade für
die abschlussklassen haben wir gesagt
die schulen sollen offen bleiben erst in
der situation als es doch massiv
eskalierte november dezember januar
haben wir gesagt wir können eben nicht
mehr zu gucken wir müssen eben auch die
schulen schließen
ich glaube nicht dass sich dass
irgendjemand von uns gewünscht hat und
wir haben alle gehofft dass wir das
thema präsenzunterricht oder zumindest
wechsel unterricht aufrechterhalten zu
können dass das von allen der wunsch
gewesen ist wir haben doch gerade beim
thema testen oder eben auch beim thema
ausstattung für digitalen unterricht ist
eine menge passiert im netz aber am
leben
aber erheblich das gehalt habe ja das
stimmt da war mir nicht mal mehr
erkenntnisse ja und eben auch zur
kenntnis nehmen dass man am ende eben
doch die gastronomie vor den schulen
wieder geöffnet hat vielleicht noch
einen punkt um sie reinzuholen frau
krause ich habe schon gerade gesagt sie
haben
tochter sind alleinerziehend die neun
jahre alt ist die gerade in die vierte
klasse geht und was erleben sie bei ihr
in diesem jahr was hat das jahr mit ihr
gemacht was gab's dafür hoch sind für
tiefs es ist uns jetzt ist es so dass
ich denke das vieh ist an unserer schule
gelaufen ist sicherlich ein ziemliches
negativbeispiel ist für deutschland
nichtsdestotrotz denke ich ich würde ja
noch ein paar punkte eigenleben genannt
worden sind auch dass zb das thema das
in distanz um brecht so viel passiert
ist dass man nicht so viel zeit hatte
eine pandemie war und das team anders
wir haben kinder uni ist ein jahr ihres
lebens eine sehr lange zeit das heißt
wir haben 7 89 jährige kinder war es ein
jahr fast zehn prozent ihres lebens und
in dieser zeit ist aus meiner sicht
wirklich viel passiert das heißt als
beispiel nennen im ersten block kind
geht in brandenburg zur schule haben wir
von dem leader per e-mail arbeitsblätter
und zettel bekommen die abzuarbeiten
wir hatten keinerlei kontakt zu lehrern
bis auf zwei anrufe wir haben keine
videokonferenzen hatten gar nichts das
heißt wie beschulung meiner tochter
wurde komplett gemeine ende es gar keine
schule in sich auch gekümmert hat und
das ist bis heute aus meiner sicht auch
fast gleich geblieben
wenn denn auch halte es weiterhin so
dass wir zwar wechsel unterricht aber
wechseln unterricht bedeutet bei uns
mitnichten dass die halbe klasse
unterrichtet wird zum beispiel sondern
dass meine tochter alle zwei wochen
schule in voller flottenstärke hat und
zwar von 92 minuten am tag und ich
glaube das ist nicht sinn dass wechsel
unterrichts dass mein kind in voller
klasse in die schule hier gleichzeitig
dass das alle zwei wochen passiert und
das war mein kind ein infektionsrisiko
ausgesetzt und dem der wechsel und heißt
eigentlich verhindern sollte und damit
möchte ich nur sagen dass ich immer
wieder hören politik bemüht sich die
politik macht die politik tut das ist
aber nicht das was ankomme und ich muss
auch sagen ich bin am eigenen
versprechen sind gebrochen worden die
die politik wollte den kindern oberste
priorität geben das muss ich seit einem
jahr lebe ist dass die kinder scheinbar
in unserer gesellschaft überhaupt keine
jugend genießen
das heißt ein was getan wird geht es um
andere dinge und frau carlitscheck
aus eben aus wir eindrucksvoll genommen
sagt öffnungen anderen bereichen was
muss man gegeneinander abwägen
es gibt den gesundheitsschutz thema
anschauen muss und dann kann ich nur
sagen wenn es um gesundheitsschutz
wirklich ihn würde und sie deshalb sagen
dass ein präsenzunterricht möglich ist
oder der präsident so recht etwas
gestaltet werden muss zb durch einen
wechsel und dem kleinen klassen oder
worden wie es bei uns nicht da alles
dann hätten wir mal sich darum kümmern
müssen was eine art vater des tanz und
deutschland gestellt und zwar online
unterricht und es heißt dass das nehme
ich einmal auf eure frau pause kurz und
weiter an frau karla check denn das ist
ja jetzt nicht von uns so dass wir
versucht haben hier drei eltern und
schüler zu finden die jetzt das ganz
exotisch wahrgenommen hätten in
deutschland sondern ich würde mal
behaupten dass es absoluter mainstream
dass schüler und eltern sagen wir haben
das gefühl dass wir mit der situation
überfordert wurden dass wir allein
gelassen wurden dass wir eben nicht
wichtig waren der politik und ich
unterstelle ihnen da wirklich guten
willen frau carlitscheck aber ihr arm
ist offenbar nicht lang genug gewesen
ihre kraft nicht groß genug gewesen es
ist einfach bei den schülern und eltern
nicht angekommen die haben nicht gemerkt
dass sie auf irgend einer
prioritätenliste oben stand
die haben das gemerkt dass sie ganz
unten standen dass sie unwichtig waren
naja ich glaube dass in dieser situation
in der wir uns seit gut oder bisschen
mehr als einem jahr befinden
der ist wenn man das gefühl dass es
jetzt wirklich auch reicht bei einem das
gleiche ist und dass familien gerade
unter besonderem druck gestanden haben
also da kam alles zusammen homeschooling
home office auch gerade die die die
zustände zu hause sind ja auch nicht
darauf ausgerichtet dass die ganze
familie in den ganzen tag zusammen sind
wir sehen eben auch dass schule
wesentlich mehr ist als eben nur
unterricht sondern das in schule viel
viel mehr stattfindet was wir vielleicht
vorher auch so in der form gar nicht
wahrgenommen haben ich bin an der stelle
auch dabei dass die zumutungen in dem
letzten jahr wirklich riesengroß waren
ich will aber trotzdem noch mal sagen
wir haben von vornherein dem thema
möglichst lange präsenzunterricht
aufrecht zu erhalten schon eine
priorität eingeräumt und haben ja aus
genau dem grunde obwohl uns als lehrer
als bund auch ein stück weit an der
stelle die hände gebunden sind ich haben
wir uns da einzumischen wie das im
einzelnen land umgesetzt wird haben wir
aber sehr schnell dafür gesorgt dass zum
beispiel eben endgeräte für schülerinnen
und schüler am anfang war die diskussion
wir können unsere schülerinnen und
schülerinnen und schüler gar nicht alle
erreichen
dann war die frage ja wie ist das denn
mit der ausstattung der lehrerinnen und
lehrer
da haben wir überall an den stellen wo
wir helfen konnten relativ schnell in
die tasten gegriffen haben auf der einen
seite geld zur verfügung gestellt wir
haben aber zum beispiel auch beim testen
dann geholfen das test kaputt okay dass
kapazitäten geschaffen wurden und und
und und sind aber im operativen geschäft
lassen sie mich den satz noch sagen ja
weil im operativen geschäft geht es
meistens darum vor ort eine adäquate
möglichkeit zu finden und das ist
natürlich ist einmal von bundesebene an
dieser stelle auch sehr schwer zu
erreichen haben uns immer sehr
abgestimmt wo können wir die länder
unterstützen aber dass die länder
unterschiedlich damit umgehen hat eben
auch was damit zu tun dass die
bedingungen sehr sehr unterschiedlich
wann portman ihr operatives geschäft das
finde ich fast einen spektakulären
begriff für das was dort passiert
nämlich das ist einfach schulalltag das
ist lesen und schreiben freunde treffen
spielen soziale kontakte das ist
operatives geschäft im moment frau
keller können sie einmal sagen wenn sie
ins ausland gucken auch ich habe mir das
einmal notiert in der schweiz da gehen
die kinder seit einem jahr ganz normal
in die schule dann in frankreich da
waren schulen und kitas eigentlich die
ganzen kompletten winter über geöffnet
april dann mal kurz ein paar
wochen geschlossen warum ging das dauert
wo die inzidenz werke ja auch teilweise
noch höher waren als in deutschland aber
warum ging es in deutschland nicht was
ist ihre erklärung
meine erklärung ist weil man im
endeffekt tatsächlich die schulen und
die kinder nicht als priorität hatte und
weil man dort kommt für von staatlicher
seite eine sehr einfaches instrument
hatte ein teil der bewegungsfreiheit der
bürger letztendlich einzuschränken und
damit das infektionsgeschehen sozusagen
einzuschränken man hat es aber nicht
festgemacht an der gefährlichkeit nach
dem motto in die schulen werden
zugemacht weil es so gefährlich ist dass
die schulen aussehen sondern weil es
recht einfach ist weil sie mit einer
entscheidung millionen menschen zu hause
zu belassen
und ich würde gerne darauf eingehen auf
die frage gesundheitsschutz weil vor
panik das jetzt schon mehrfach gesagt
hat es geht ja auch um den
gesundheitsschutz ihr der um den geht
ist aber die frage ist werden unsere
kinder eigentlich zu hause gelassen und
wir haben nicht in die schule gelassen
weil es ihre eigenen gesundheit schadet
oder weil sie herangezogen werden und
die gesundheit anderer menschen so
schätzt das ist interessant also werden
die erhält man die kinder zu hause vor
carlitscheck um den rest der bevölkerung
zu schützen der verdacht liegt ja nahe
weil das jetzt auch diejenigen sind die
am wenigsten geimpft sind
beziehungsweise die als letzte ihrer
impfung bekommen hält man die aus den
schulen raus damit die kinder keine
infektions treiber sind also auch kinder
können gott sei dank erkranken sie sehr
sehr selten schwer aber auch kinder
können erkranken und dann zum beispiel
an diesem long kawasaki syndrom also an
einer überschießenden immunantwort
leiden und daneben auch langfristige
erkrankungen haben am ende geht es doch
darum immer wieder diese erkrankung
möglichkeit so gering zu halten wie
möglich aber für wären das aber für wen
war aber für wen ist ja eine ganz
wichtige frage ich würde für alle das
will ich ganz bewusst an dieser stelle
nochmal sagen es geht nicht darum alte
gegen junge auszuspielen sondern einen
weg zu finden wie wir mit der pandemie
möglichst gut fertig werden und am ende
dafür sorgen dass möglichst wenig
menschen und da ist es egal ob alt oder
jung am ende sind diejenigen
junge erkranken erkranken und
langzeitfolgen davon haben die haben
dafür auch noch ein langes leben vor
sich ging wo sie dann damit leiden
darunter leiden und das ist wichtig dass
wir das auch in den fokus nehmen ja es
stimmt natürlich erkrankten weniger
junge menschen schwer und natürlich ist
dann ich sag mal das risiko so schwer zu
erkranken wesentlich geringer aber jeder
einzelne mensch der sein ganzes leben
lang hinterher an solchen erkrankungen
zu leiden hat auch das ist es wert dass
wir heute darüber reden und dass wir
denjenigen schützen so gut es geht
ich werde weiterer vorwurf von frau
keller war gerade dass man die schulen
so lange geschlossen gehalten hat weil
man das halt ganz einfach machen konnte
in der politik da brauchte es halt
einfach nur einen beschluss und dann
behalte ich das war schwieriger mit
gastronomie das war gerecht lich war das
schwieriger usw
und man hat er auch sehr schnell wütende
worte und war das so weil das man hat
das gemacht weil es so einfach ist und
vor allen dingen sind schüler und
schülerinnen am ende so eine art corona
sparschweine weil man hat das geld
gebraucht für die gastronomie um die
hilfen zu zahlen und für alles andere
eben wirtschaftshilfen zu zahlen aber
schulen zu schließen ist erst mal
günstig kurzfristig naja wenn man dieser
argumentation folgen würde dann gibt es
ja viel mehr wütende eltern als wütende
würde also das kann ja nicht richtig
sein
die argumentation dahinter ist doch eine
andere gewesen die argumentation war
doch dass gerade in den schulen viele
menschen auf engem raum zusammen sind
aus ganz unterschiedlichen hintergründen
kommen aus ganz unterschiedlichen
familien kommen und an dieser stelle
sich eben die durchmischung der
gesellschaft die ist sehr stark und
deswegen hat man irgendwann gesagt jetzt
können wir es nicht mehr verantworten
wir brauchen nur auf den auf die
notbremse zu gucken daran sehen wir doch
dass wir gesagt haben alle anderen
müssen viel früher schließen nämlich bei
einer inzidenz von 100 und für die
schulen und bildungseinrichtungen haben
wir eine instanz von 165 festgelegt
daran sieht man doch dass wir schon
erstmal noch wesentlich länger alles
dafür getan haben den präsenzunterricht
in der einen oder anderen form als
wechsel unterricht oder oder so wie es
seit vor ort ausgestaltet worden es
aufrechtzuerhalten uns ist doch die
dimension dessen was das für kinder
bedeutet sich treffen zu können und auch
leer
was das was das fürs leben bedeutet das
ist uns sehr sehr klar nur wir waren im
winter in einer situation wo plötzlich
die lage eskalierte wo wir mit unseren
infektionszahlen so hoch kam dass auch
die gefährdung von kindern an der stelle
so hoch ist dass diese diese
langzeitfolgen die werden ja immer
wahrscheinlicher je höher die die
infektion ist und deswegen kann man
irgendwann eben nicht mehr zu gucken es
geht nicht darum das eine oder andere
gegeneinander auszuspielen es bestehen
um eine pandemie in griff zu kriegen und
möglichst dafür zu sorgen dass die
schäden bei allen möglichst kleinen
blatt stehe ich habe mich gewundert frau
herr schramm dass auch sie ganz ganz
viele schüler und schülerinnen die
älteren zumindest und vor allen dingen
auch deren eltern sich das millionenfach
so gefallen lassen dass versprochen wird
dass sie priorität haben und am ende
gehen halt doch zuerst die restaurants
auf zumindest in den meisten
bundesländern
warum haben sich so viele eltern vor
allen dingen das einfach gefallen das
haben das einfach mit sich machen lassen
das kann ich nicht sagen für die eltern
ich kann nur für die schüler sagen dass
die schüler tatsächlich einfach
natürlich sehr enttäuscht sind was für
mich aber jetzt noch mal ein ganz
wichtiger punkt dass vor kalinka gerade
gesagt es geht eben nicht nur darum
tatsächlich gesundheitsschutz auch bei
den älteren sondern es gibt schlichtweg
auch die fälle bei den jüngeren wo es
gefährlich wird und daher hut vor carl
check die lösung sozusagen selbst im
ministerium arbeiten lassen die pokale
check war es die s3 leitlinien die ist
anfang dieses jahres raus gekommen
dort stand ganz klar drin wie man
schulen auch mit hohen zahlen
theoretisch auf lassen kann und ein
großer knackpunkt der dort genannt
worden ist habe mit dran gearbeitet
waren busse und bahnen und wir erleben
jetzt gerade die schulen machen wieder
auf wir erleben jetzt dass es immer
wieder heißt sie müssen auf die jungen
menschen achten und haben aber daneben
die vollen busse und bahnen und das ist
etwas das wir seit anderthalb jahren
beobachten und seit anderthalb jahren
schreien alle entzerrt dass es passiert
nichts und das ist einfach nur als ein
beispiel für viele sachen wo die lösung
allen auf der hand liegt die eltern
schreiben es die spieler anschreiben und
die politik handelt einfach nicht
letzter frage weil ich weiß dass bei
ihnen die zeit knapp wird frau
carlitscheck können sie garantieren dass
nach den sommerferien zumindest unter
bestimmten bedingungen wieder normaler
unterricht lloyd normaler
präsenzunterricht in deutschland
sind gut denn die impfkampagne nimmt
richtig fahrt auf je mehr menschen sich
impfen lassen umso leichter ist es die
zu schützen die eben nicht geimpft
worden sind wir werden trotzdem gerade
bei den unter zwölfjährigen nach den
sommerferien also zum schulbeginn
wahrscheinlich noch keinen impfstoff
haben so dass wir auf jeden fall noch
mit sicherheitskonzepten und mit testen
die situation im griff halten müssen
aber ich bin da sehr optimistisch noch
mal um es auf den punkt zu bringen das
klingt in richtung einer garantie aber
nicht so richtig nach einer garantie
also präsenzunterricht garantiert nach
den sommerferien ja oder nein
lieber herr weise garantien kann eben in
einer pandemie niemand geben weil wir
einfach nicht wissen was passiert wir
müssen immer wieder auf aktuelle lage
reagieren ich habe ihnen die
rahmenbedingungen skizziert dass das
eben jetzt fahrt aufnimmt dass wir auch
die bis zwölfjährigen bis zum ende des
sommers geimpft haben können und das ist
halt das ist schon ein ist doch mal ein
guter fahrschein dafür dass eben auch
die kleineren wenn wir sie noch nicht
impfen können dass sie dann trotzdem
ziemlich viel normalität wie unterricht
aber sie sagen immer wieder das müssen
wir noch einmal richtig fix kriegen sie
sagen immer wieder ist es hängt fall
impfen ab das heißt entscheidend ist für
den präsenzunterricht wie viele schüler
und schülerinnen geimpft sind wenn nicht
viele schüler und schülerinnen geimpft
sind zumindest über zwölf jahren auch
kein präsenzunterricht naja wenn die ins
identen jetzt weiter runter gehen jeder
einzelne der geimpft wird trägt dazu bei
dass die ihm dass die infektions lage
besser wird dass die pandemie schritt
für schritt ab
wir müssen jetzt einfach gucken wie gut
auch ist einmal die situation im sommer
wirkt wie sehr wir die zahlen runter
kriegen jetzt auch durch nachverfolgung
und durch quarantäne
wir müssen alle die instrumente und alle
möglichkeiten die wir jetzt haben die
müssen wir so gut wie es geht nutzen
dass wir die zahl der infektionen pro
monat 1000 so klein wie möglich kriegen
und umso leichter wird es uns fallen im
herbst wenn das impfen ja noch weiter
fortgeschritten ist daneben auch die
situation im griff zu halten aber noch
mal ganz kurz weil das wichtige sind
vier wochen gehen hier in berlin
zumindest die sommerferien los das ist
in bayern da noch ein bisschen später
aber berlin ist ganz früh dran wie
andere bundesländer auch da bleibt nicht
mehr viel zeit in diesem fenster zu
impfen ich würde jetzt mal ganz
realistisch sagen kein einziger dieser
schüler wird außer durch private
kontakte über ein haushalts und so
weiter geht werden zumindest
flächendeckend
wird das nicht mehr in den vier wochen
das heißt das problem wird in den
sommerferien nicht behoben das heißt wir
stehen direkt davor zu entscheiden was
passierte nach den sommerferien und sie
sagen werden bis dahin nicht
flächendeckend geben führt kein
regelunterricht nein das habe ich nicht
gesagt außerdem kann man ja jetzt wenn
wir sehen dass wahrscheinlich ende mai
anfang juni das impfen für die bis zu
zwölf also 16 bis zwölfjährigen möglich
ist wird es ja auch möglich sein sich
vor ort im land zu überlegen wie wollen
wir denn da ran gehen dass wir gerade
die jüngeren jetzt möglichst schnell
impfen einmal ist es ein signal dass wir
natürlich einen fokus auf die jungen
menschen haben
und das zweite ist dass wir das eben
auch systematisch dann organisieren
können sie sagen in vier wochen fangen
die ferien an
aber nichtsdestotrotz sind die
kinderärzte er noch da man kann ja jetzt
auch systematisch sich mit den kinder
ärzten oder eben auch zum beispiel mit
den amtsärzten überlegen wie will man
denn eine impfkampagne gerade für die
jüngeren fahren so dass das möglich ist
in den bundesländern wo man noch länger
schule hat ist es einfacher sie zu
erreichen aber nichtsdestotrotz kann man
doch jeden jungen menschen und seinen
eltern dann ein angebot machen innerhalb
einer bestimmten zeit sich impfen zu
lassen man muss ich glaube ich jetzt
einmal überlegen mit was für strukturen
in dem jeweiligen bundesland kann man
das am besten live klassenweise impfen
wäre dass die möglichkeit ganz kurz noch
klassenweise impfen
naja impfen bleibt freiwillig und am
ende ist das bis zum 18 lebensjahr immer
auch eine entscheidung die die eltern
mittragen so dann muss man eben im
vorfeld sich die genehmigung der eltern
einholen lassen dass die kinder geimpft
werden dürfen aber dann ist das
natürlich eine möglichkeit dass in der
schule zu organisieren warum nicht ich
danke ganz herzlich dafür dass sie heute
all dem ärger auch zur verfügung
gestanden haben sich gestellt haben hier
bei bild.de danke für die antworten frau
carlitscheck auch wenn manches das ist
leider so dass haben wir in den letzten
zehn jahren immer wieder gelernte vor
allen dingen der bildungspolitik im
unklaren bleibt und oft weiß man eben
nicht
das ist jetzt eigentlich was bedeutet
das eigentlich für mich vielen dank
erstmal für sie jetzt lasst hier in den
abend ich weiß sie haben termine danke
frau carlitscheck möchte noch einmal
ganz kurz hier ist schluss
machen mit ihnen auch frau krause wenn
sie das hören dass das weitergeht im
sommer möglicherweise mit dem wechsel
unterricht nach den sommerferien noch
mal was geht ihnen da durch den kopf und
wie vermitteln sie das vor allen dingen
ihrer tochter als schwierig und wir
hören hier die ganze zeit 1 das wieder
unterricht garantieren dass noch in
welcher form er garantiert ist und dass
er oben drauf werden oder nicht ja
wichtig ist auch dass ich auch in diesem
zusammenhang auch zu betonen ich bin
auch ärzten
wir haben aktuell keine impfstoff der
für unter 60 und zu lassen ist das heißt
wir reden ja auch immer über einen
impfstoffwerk duell noch nicht
zugelassen dass der quasi zur bedingung
gemacht
ein unterricht nach den sommerferien im
trab halten zu können
und das finde ich es nicht schwierig
denn was ich habe ja und dann nach allen
dann sehen dass manche oder auch in
anderen ländern viele weitere im
fortschritts sind wen ist das wenn die
fallzahlen wenn erwachsene fallen die
kinder auch ihnen nicht mehr so hohe
fallzahlen haben
und bevor wir vielleicht über kinder
entsprechen als voraussetzung beim
schulbesuch sei erstmal abwarten was wir
schaffen wir wachstum zu impfen und dann
vielleicht weiter sehen anstatt jetzt
schon bedingungen an den schulbesuch zu
knüpfen
okay auch von ihnen nochmal final wenn
sie das gehört haben nach den
sommerferien geht es möglicherweise ganz
genauso mit gewurschtel weiter und wenn
überhaupt und wenn ein bisschen gm führt
dann hängt möglicherweise davon ab aber
wie das organisiert wird in den
bundesländern völlig unklar
und ob die lehrer der überhaupt
mitmachen und keine ahnung also im
grunde hat man ja dass es auf jeden fall
klar kein konzept für die zeit nach den
sommerferien
ich würde diese fatalistische
einschätzung absolut leider teilen weil
ich sehe jetzt eben auch kein konzept
wir haben ja jetzt gerade am schlusswort
von frau k litscher gehört dass die
läuft auf einen im druck letztendlich
hinaus und ich würde mich verstanden
auch anschließen ich sehe das sehr
skeptisch obwohl ich meine kinder mit
allem anderen habe ihn sehen lassen sehe
ich gerade auch die impfung von kindern
hier mit einem noch eben noch nicht
einmal zugelassenen impfstoff und selbst
wenn
zugelassen ist ist er ganz neu ich sehe
die notwendigkeit nicht ich und da würde
ich noch einmal betonen unsere kinder
haben schon auf eine ganze menge
verzichtet und eine ganze menge
rücksicht genommen auf eine ältere
generation weil es ist ja man kann ja
sagen man möchte niemanden ausspielen
faktisch haben wir aber diese kinder
bereits ausgespielt
meine kinder haben in der schule auch
von lehrern sätze gehört wie ihr müsst
ihr bis zu hause bleiben weil sonst
drohen eure großeltern zu sterben ist
wenn das ist ein gängiges argument dass
wir jetzt seit 16 monaten hören wie
argumentiert wird warum kinder auch die
großeltern nicht treffen sollen das
heißt wir haben diesen kindern schon
aufgebürdet dass sie verzichten sollen
damit die ältere generation überlegt das
kann man machen akut das kann aber kein
prinzip bleiben weil in meinen augen
rang diese kinder sowieso schon doppelt
bezahlt sie können ja nicht nachholen
ich möchte auch nicht mehr hören die
kinder sollen
wir müssen dann nachholen ein kind kann
sein leben nicht nachholen es kann eine
wichtige entwicklungsschritte kann es
nicht nachholen das können wir als
erwachsene vielleicht machen ein kind
kann das nicht und unsere kinder werden
im übrigen diese ganze pandemie noch
bezahlen denn alles was wir an der
wirtschaftlichen kaputt schlagen haben
wir unsere kinder in den schulden die
sich hier auch häufen später alles
komplett abbezahlen und ich finde es ist
jetzt an der reihe zuschauen wie können
wir kindern ihr leben ermöglichen weil
noch mal sie sind nicht gefährdet die
kinder die infektionszahlen sind bei
kindern auf da aber sie sind nicht akut
gefährdet
besonders gefährlich zu erkranken wir
haben die zeit von rk ii ja das heißt
wenn die erwachsenen sich selber
schützen gibt es gar keinen grund mehr
warum wir die meisten impfungen machen
müssen bei kindern und das würde ich
gern vermeiden wollten schon gar nicht
kann es sein dass es zur bedingung
gemacht wird dass meine kinder
präsenzunterricht bekommen dass wenn ich
ne unverschämtheit überhaupt jetzt schon
darüber zu diskutieren
herr schramm letzte frage an sie hatte
ich vorher schon mal einmal probiert
über ihr abitur zu sprechen weil ich das
doch sehr respektvoll
sagen möchte in dieser zeit überhaupt
eine so große leistung zu erbringen er
hat das verdient tatsächlich respekt wie
groß war denn die last dass in dieser
corona zeit zu machen eben die prüfung
ablegen zu müssen und die ganzen den
ganzen lernstoff sich auf zu schaffen
ohne richtigen kontakt zu den lehrern zu
haben oder zumindest weniger als normal
natürlich war es so dass man sich da
viele gedanken gemacht hat wie ist die
grundlage habe ich genug unterricht
gehabt und unter beiden und ist es
natürlich auf meine aufgabe gewesen das
große ganze zusammenzuhalten und auch zu
schauen wie es bei den anderen läuft und
das war tatsächlich ob man es glaubt
oder nicht die viel größere sorge in den
zeiten weil ich natürlich den mitschüler
erlebt er habe die tatsächlich einfach
nicht die möglichkeit hatten sich
vorzubereiten in dem maße wie es andere
konnten die vielleicht sich ihr zimmer
teilen mussten rund und und und das
problem ist tatsächlich auch dass wir
jetzt nicht nur den jahrgang haben der
jetzt seinen abschluss gemacht hat
sondern auch für die folgenden jahrgänge
und da kann ich mich meinen gegnerinnen
einfach nur anschließen es wird
konzeptlos und ich habe auch große sorge
gerade wenn es ums impfen geht ich
glaube nämlich es gibt auch viele
schüler die sich gerne impfen lassen
wollen dann müssen wir da eine gewisse
priorität legen und das impfen muss
sobald der stoff da ist ganz prioritär
an junge menschen gehen wird ihr abitur
immer weniger wert sein als das ja eins
zwei drei jahrgänge vor ihnen ich glaube
das abitur ist nicht weniger wert und
ich bin auch kein fan von diesem wagen
prinzip
ich glaube wenn überhaupt ist es nochmal
ein qualitäts stempelt oben drauf wenn
wir uns anschauen
anderthalb jahre eben damit verbracht
sich auf eine finale prüfung
vorzubereiten unter den schwersten
bedingungen dann glaube ich dass die
schüler eher gestärkt aus dieser zeit
rausgehen können und sagen können ja
etwas trotz dieser bedingungen geschafft
anstatt dass sie sein können und gott es
ist doch die weniger wert als es ist
schon irgendwie ist in der situation in
der tat seien sie stolz auf ihre
leistung herr schramm danke für die
diskussion heute danke frau keller
danke frau krause nach brandenburg ihnen
und ihren kindern daumen drücken dass es
eben doch spätestens nach den
sommerferien wieder losgeht und
möglicherweise doch zuvor auch schon
zumindest in brandenburg sind sie ja
schon ein bisschen weiter wenigstens das
als hier in der hauptstadt in berlin und
als auch in vielen anderen bundesländern
ihnen alles gute für die zeit bis zu den
sommerferien und wie gesagt auch danach
das waren die richtigen fragen heute mit
ist dann mit minister peter altmaier
wirtschaftsminister und auch mit anja
karliczek der bundesbildungsministerin
die sich hier dem ärger vieler schüler
und eltern gestellt hat danke dafür noch
einmal und am nächsten sonntag geht es
weiter
21.45 hierbei bild
[Musik]